Nos dicen: "Multiplica (1.45 x 10⁸) (9.2 x
10¯¹²) (3.01 x 10¯⁵), y expresa el producto
tanto en notación decimal como científica".
Entonces tenemos 1.45 x 10⁸ por, y, bueno,
podríamos expresar de nuevo esto usando los
paréntesis como está indicado aquí, pero mejor
vamos a usar el símbolo de multiplicación: x 9.2
x 10¯¹² y después x 3.01 x 10¯⁵. Recuerda: tener
expresiones separadas por paréntesis significa que
simplemente vamos a multiplicar esta expresión,
por esta expresión, por esta expresión, y dado
que sólo tenemos multiplicaciones no importa
el orden en el que multipliquemos; con esto
en mente, podemos cambiar el orden por aquí.
Así que esto va a ser lo mismo que 1.45 x 9.2 x
3.01 por -y utilicemos el mismo color púrpura-,
por 10⁸ x 10¯¹² x 10¯⁵; y esto es bastante útil,
ya que ahora podemos agrupar todas las potencias
de 10 por aquí. Pongamos un paréntesis y por
acá tenemos todo lo que no es potencia de 10,
así que podemos simplificar: tenemos la misma
base que es 10 y podemos sumar los exponentes,
entonces esto será igual a 10⁸ ¯¹² ¯⁵, 8 - 12 - 5;
mientras que por acá, a la izquierda -déjame sacar
la calculadora-, tenemos 1.45 -podemos hacerlo a
mano, pero es mucho más rápido con la calculadora
y es menos probable que cometamos un error- x 9.2
x 3.01, esto es igual a 40.1534. Entonces tenemos
40.1534, y, claro, esto multiplica a 10 elevado a
esta potencia, que si simplificamos el exponente
tenemos 40.1534 x 10 a la, 8 - 12 que es -4 - 5
es -9, x 10 elevado a la potencia -9. Ahora bien,
podemos creer que esto ya está en notación
científica, pues aquí tenemos un número que
multiplica a una potencia de 10, sin embargo, esto
no es exactamente notación científica, ya que para
estar en notación científica se debe cumplir que
este número de aquí sea mayor o igual a 1 y menor
a 10. Obviamente este número no es menor a 10,
entonces, para que esté en notación científica
lo que queremos es un único dígito, distinto de
0, por aquí, después del punto decimal, y después
lo demás. Y podemos ver que por acá tenemos dos
dígitos, tenemos un número que es mayor o igual
a 10, así que esto no está en notación científica
porque, recuerda que este número debe de ser menor
a 10 y mayor o igual a 1, así que escribamos
primero este número en notación científica.
Este número es igual a 4.01534 x 10, y bueno, una
forma de pensar en esto es que para pasar de 40 a
4 tuvimos que recorrer el punto decimal un lugar
hacia la izquierda, mover el punto decimal hacia
la izquierda una vez para pasar de 40 a 4 es lo
mismo que dividir entre 10, así que para conservar
el mismo valor tenemos que multiplicar ahora por
10, es decir, dividimos entre 10 y después por
acá multiplicamos por 10; entonces no se altera o
cambia el valor de la expresión. También podemos
decir que 4.0 y todos estos decimales multiplicado
por 10 es igual a 40.1534, por lo tanto nos
quedará 4 punto y todos estos decimales por 10
a la primera potencia, que es lo mismo que 10,
y esto que multiplica a 10¯⁹. Una vez más tenemos
potencias de 10, entonces, como tenemos la misma
base, podemos sumar los exponentes: esto de aquí
va a ser igual a 10 elevado a la potencia 1 - 9,
que será 10¯⁸, es decir, todo esto será igual
a 4.01534 x 10¯⁸. Y ahora sí, ya lo tenemos
escrito en notación científica. Ahora nos piden
que expresemos el resultado tanto en notación
decimal como científica, y cuando nos piden que lo
escribamos en notación decimal lo que nos piden es
hacer esta multiplicación, es decir, queremos
expandir este número. Para hacer esto vamos a
escribir estos dígitos, tenemos: 4, 0, 1, 5, 3,
4, y si sólo observamos este número empezamos con
el punto decimal por aquí. Ahora, cada vez que
dividimos entre 10 o cada vez que multiplicamos
por 10¯¹, lo que hacemos es recorrer el punto
decimal un lugar hacia la izquierda, multiplicar
por 10¯¹ es lo mismo que dividir entre 10, es
decir, movemos el punto decimal un lugar a la
izquierda. Aquí estamos multiplicando por 10¯⁸,
o podemos decir que estamos dividiendo entre 10 a
la octava potencia, entonces tenemos que mover
el punto decimal a la izquierda ocho lugares,
tenemos que mover el punto decimal ocho lugares
a la izquierda. Y una manera de acordarse es que
este es un número muy, muy, muy, muy pequeño, que
si lo multiplicamos por este número voy a obtener
un número muy, muy, muy pequeño, por lo tanto,
tenemos que recorrer el punto decimal hacia la
izquierda. Ahora bien, si este fuera 10⁸, entonces
este sería un número muy, muy, muy grande,
y tendríamos que recorrer el punto decimal hacia
la derecha. Pero, bueno, en este caso este número
debe de ser menor que 4.01534, así que movamos
el punto decimal ocho lugares a la izquierda:
si movemos el punto decimal un lugar a la
izquierda llegamos hasta aquí, y en los
siguientes siete lugares que nos movamos hacia
la izquierda vamos a poner ceros, entonces uno,
dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis, siete ceros, y
pondremos al final el punto decimal, y un 0 antes
del punto decimal para tener todo claro. Y tomando
en cuenta este valor vamos a tener ocho dígitos:
uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis, siete, ocho
dígitos. La mejor forma de pensar en esto es que
empezamos con el punto decimal por aquí y nos
movimos uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis,
siete, ocho lugares a la izquierda, eso es lo que
pasa cuando multiplicamos por 10 ¯⁸, y obtenemos
este número de aquí. Y cuando vemos un número como
este, podemos apreciar por qué escribimos números
en notación científica, ya que esto es mucho
más fácil de escribir y ocupa menos espacio,
y podemos darnos una idea aproximada de qué tan
grande es este número. Esta forma es más difícil
de escribir, pudimos haber puesto un 0 de menos o
un 0 más y equivocarnos, además la persona que lo
lee tiene que contar cuántos ceros hay para darse
cuenta de qué tan grande es este número. Nosotros
obtuvimos uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis,
siete ceros, y más este último dígito nos lleva
a este 8; pero esta forma de expresar un número es
mucho más complicada que la notación científica.